I was still glad to be sitting here with
you thank you uh I saw you in concert
with Taylor Swift with my two girls Oh
what husband was there too and they are
big fans of yours now
they love listen to your music thank you
and so generation after generation your
music speaks to so many people what is
that feeling for you what it's it's
funny because you don't really expect
well I mean with what can I say yeah
when you write music you don't really
know what's gonna happen with it
I usually write songs for myself and so
if they go out and make people happy
then you've done your job I guess but
it's been interesting to watch the way
songs have developed and if we take the
song that I did but Taylor for example
in summer of 69 when that song came out
it wasn't really a hit it became a hit
sort of much later worldwide it was you
know it did well in America and Canada
but outside of there it would never de
never did and now it's it's a it's a
it's a worldwide it's a worldwide hit
and it never charted anywhere so it's
interesting to see how music sort of has
a way of getting there
not necessarily immediately mm-hmm
mm-hmm
and fourth the fourteenth studio album
coming out yes shine a light why the
names shine a light well I kind of wrote
it at the time
when I was losing my father last summer
and I just thought an ode to to someone
who's had a great life and so when I
wrote the chorus about you know
everywhere you go shine a light and let
everybody know and I just I just parked
it because I didn't I didn't finish the
idea because I was so involved in the
other work that I was doing at the time
I only finished it last syrup in the
autumn last year when I was in Dublin I
I done a show there and the next night
Ed Sheeran was playing at the venue next
to us and so I went to see Ed's show
became friends with Edie because we
hadn't met before hmm and over a couple
of emails I sent him in the idea I said
what do you think did you want to help
me finish this and he said yeah and
that's how the song came back so I that
so that's the single shine a light of
this album and I expected a duo between
you two on the album why didn't I was an
IDI not on the album I don't know it was
just it was it's what it's the way it is
you know and you know one of the things
I love that you just said that artists
when they make music they're in a place
in their lives in their career and that
influences our music and you were just
talking about your dad how would you
describe the journey of this album well
one of the things about the way I work
is I sort of sort of assemble ideas and
harcum I collaborate mostly I work with
a guy called Jim Vallance and I've
worked with for many years and we just
spend the last couple years I've been
working on a musical with him in New
York and so while we were working on the
musical I was just working on other
ideas and trying to put together this
album so it's it was a lot of a lot of
writing it's like for that for musical
alone we wrote over 30 songs and and for
the album there's another 12 so maybe 4
to 15 so the songs always keep coming
you know it doesn't necessarily mean
they're gonna do anything but music
keeps happening are you consistently
writing every day not every day but
ideas happen all the time yeah another
collaboration you did was genuine the
blog Jennifer Lopez I mean how did that
happen did you guys get in the studio
together did you give her a call or it
was just a concept that came up the the
song that's on the album with Jennifer
Lopez is coach that's how strong our
love
and I'd actually recorded the song mixed
it finished it and then I've done you
know what I'd like to sing this with
somebody I think I'd like to find some
and and and I thought of Jennifer I
thought I'd be interesting too I'd met
her many many years ago in in Spain and
I thought so I wrote an email to her
manager I said do you think Jennifer
would like to do this I got any bad back
said yes and that's how it happened and
we instudio together well because I
finish mine yeah and so I just asked her
to work on it mm-hmm and you're talking
about the Broadway show congratulations
on that thank one of my favorite films
pretty woman Julia Roberts and it's out
there now what was it like crane that
music which imbalance and creating those
moments for pretty woman well it was
great we had we had a couple years to do
it so and the way we went about it was
sort of just one let's get the let's get
the opening song let's get the song
after that and we worked on it and
worked on it and worked on up almost
until the day of opening the show you're
kidding yeah and what was it like seeing
her for the first time all coming
together well I saw it in many many it
can incantations because there was
everything from workshops to dress
rehearsals to full rehearsals to
previews in Chicago to the final opening
night in Broadway now when you create
all this music I understand that you
like to be a perfectionist and in doing
tours and your music one is there a
person in your life that opinions
matters the most to you
myself hmm I mean to be fair I I really
I work hard on making ideas as good as
they and try and try not to be Precious
about being locked into one thing so
allowing yourself the freedom to if a
better idea or better arrangement can
can happen or a better lyric or me the
verse and when you're working on a
musical you have to be open to a barrage
of changes that are going to happen
because the director or the musical
director or or who knew that's gonna be
there's gonna be influences about how
the story gets told and is the story
poignant to that exact specific moment
in the in the show so you know and
that's in that and in that context and
and then and then in your own context
you know for example with if we go to
this song I did with Jennifer Lopez for
example even though I recorded with her
and we finished that and we did the mix
even up into the last day before I had
to deliver the album I totally remixed
the record changed the instrumentation
because I felt like it wasn't modern
enough what I'd done and so I worked
with a different producer on creating a
new a new arrangement for the song
mm-hmm and that's what's on the record
in fact if you're if you're curious the
vinyl the original vinyl record which is
coming out in March I think there's a
limited edition of it I don't know how
many records there are only the cover is
different and the music the inside the
records differ and that has their very
original mix with Jenny and I and then
that's gonna fade out because the new
version is taking over so Wow yeah hi
what's your definition of success I
don't know I don't really think about
that you don't know yeah you just love
making music well it's it's it can't
help myself yes it's always trying to
find the next thing and what's what
we're gonna do so
you